han pasado dos meses desde que Maxi fue
detenida por la policía la moral y
llevada luego con muerte cerebral a un
hospital no muy lejos de aquí e Irán es
un país totalmente
diferente muy con una mayor indignación
de la población de la que había entonces
pero también con una mayor división
entre aquellos que apoyan al sistema de
la República islámica y aquellos
especialmente liderados por los jóvenes
y por las mujeres que piden un cambio en
el sistema y es que esos miles de
jóvenes que se movilizaron en un
comienzo bajo ese eslogan de mujer vida
y Libertad sansen de guías allí
rápidamente cambiaron su eslogan a
muerte al dictador pidiendo por mayores
cambios en la república islámica Y eso
no solamente en las grandes ciudades
sino también en pequeñas poblaciones de
muchas regiones del país y se hicieron
más fuertes en dos grandes provincias
fronterizas en el sistema luchistán en
el sur y en el kurdistán iraní De dónde
es proveniente
giras protestas continúan y la represión
es cada vez mayor el gobierno de la
República islámica acusa a los grupos
opositores kurdos de liderar estas
protestas y hoy atacaba bases de estos
grupos en el curtista aquí como lo había
hecho en el pasado pero las protestas
Aunque ya no son tan extendidas en la
calle debido a la represión de las
autoridades que han capturado al menos
15.000 personas Si siguen existiendo de
manera simbólica y especialmente en las
universidades donde los jóvenes piden la
liberación de esos presos especialmente
a los estudiantes y ponen como línea
roja las condenas apenas de muerte Ellos
dicen que si esto sucede ya habrían ya
será el fin para la República islámica
pero ayer ya se conoció que la primera
persona había sido condenada a muerte no
se conoció su nombre dicen que quemó un
edificio gubernamental Pero hay otras
personas que estarían esperando la misma
condena para los próximos tres días
están convocadas nuevas prote y paros
nacionales y a la espera de saber cómo
reacciona la población